wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
es steht ihm jetzt noch 1000
die möbel du hast ein möbel ja ich habe
einen schrank im bett und eine matratze
alles aus dem second händlern 0 betragen
da muss ich mich ja gleich noch mal
duschen 8 nico und ich mache das oder
[Applaus]
aber nur unter einer bedingung hh du
musst beim einem fotoprojekt mit welches
projekt also pass auf ich möchte gerne
deutsche redewendung mit fotos
darstellen
wow ich möchte gerne alles wortwörtlich
umsetzen
das klingt cool kann ich die fotos dann
auch wenn meine sprachübungen benutzen
also bist du dabei im moment habe ich
eigentlich genug freizeit das geht ich
freue mich drauf super und dann kannst
du dir schon überlegen welche
redewendung wichtig und und ganz
besonders interessant sind und sich
entscheiden und wir unterhalten uns
morgen nochmal spitze unterschrank